ANTONY PASSEMARD:
Welcome, everybody.
I hope you can hear us well.
I'm really excited
to be here today
to talk about hardware
root of trust with Google
cloud IoT core
and microchip, one
of our great partner
for a bunch of security
products and other
connectivity products.
My name is Antony Passemard.
I lead the Google Cloud IoT
product management team.
And I'm with Nicolas
Shieli from Microchip.
Nicolas, want to
introduce yourself?
NICOLAS SHIELI: Sure.
Thank you, Antony.
Hello, everyone.
So my name is Nicolas Shieli.
I'm managing the marketing and
application [INAUDIBLE] team
for Microchip, for the
secret products group.
ANTONY PASSEMARD: Great.
Thanks, Nicolas.
So today, a little
bit of an agenda.
We're going to talk about
why security matters for IoT.
It may be obvious
to a lot of you,
but definitely something
to remind people.
We're going to talk about
what does root of trust
mean, really, for IoT devices?
And that's an important
concept that we're
talking about in that webinar,
so it's something really
interesting to look at.
We're going to talk about the
difference between hardware
and software security,
the big debate for IoT
and one of the key
point we're addressing
in that presentation.
Then we're going to
look at Cloud IoT Core,
just get a little bit of an
overview of the new service
that we launched
fairly recently,
something that is
currently in beta
and we want to learn more about.
Then we'll look at a secure flow
between Google and Microchip,
which is really key to the
partnership we have together
between the two companies.
We're going to talk a bit about
firmware validation for IoT
devices.
It's very important if--
you want to make sure what's
running on the device is
what is supposed to be running.
And then, how do you get
started with all of that?
So without further ado,
I'll pass it on to Nicolas
to talk about Microchip
and the security solutions
that they have.
NICOLAS SHIELI:
Thank you, Antony.
So just a few words.
Microchip is a $4
billion revenue company,
headquartered near Phoenix
in Chandler, Arizona.
And we are primarily
focused on microcontroller,
high-performance
microcontroller digital signal
controllers, microprocessors.
A lot of mixed-signal,
analog, interface and security
solutions.
Also, clock and timing
solutions, and obviously,
wireless and wired
connectivity solutions.
And then finally, also, EEPROM
and Flash memory solutions.
Overall, Microchip, with
the security solutions,
we've been very active
in the IoT space
to try and simplify how
we can secure IT devices
and make that
connectivity secure.
So let's look at why IoT
security is that important.
So if you're looking at
what happened recently,
there is clearly an acceleration
of the number of attacks
that are happening in
the world, typically
targeting IoT devices.
But overall, basically
attacks are becoming
more and more sophisticated.
And one common thread
among most of those attacks
is the fact that it's all
about the key material
or the [INAUDIBLE] materials
that are in the devices.
That is typically too
close to the software.
So the software
ends up leaking out
some of that critical material.
So in that context, we worked
very closely with Google
on trying to find an
easy but very secure
solution to secure IoT devices.
So looking at-- so that
part, and basically we
looking at having basically
a hardware root of trust
for connected devices.
And what is-- how
do I root of trust?
So basically, you need to
have two basic concepts.
So you need to
have a verifiable,
trustable, and unique identity
for a connected device.
But you also need to make
sure that basically allows
you to verify the device
that is connecting
to the service is the one that
is supposed to be connecting.
The second thing is
you need to make sure
that you can validate
the device firmware
and make sure that what
is running on the device
is indeed the genuine firmware.
So device identity.
It's essentially a little
bit like a birth certificate
for each device.
So it needs to be unique,
verifiable, and trustable.
So it's based on
cryptographic key pairs.
So you have one private
key and a public key.
They are mathematically related.
And you need to--
so the whole identity
hinges on the fact
that the private
key remains private
during the whole
lifetime of the product.
So if the private key
is ever disclosed,
that means someone can abuse
the identity of that device
and can basically
put the connection
to the remote service.
So you need to be able to
verify with the public key
that this device
certificate is valid,
and basically, you need to
make sure that, overall,
the private key is always
private during the whole
lifetime of the product.
So the bottom line
is you have to have
a strong isolation of the
private keys from the users.
You don't want any of
the private keys of any
of the devices to
be, at any point
in time, exposed to
any of the users.
You want to isolate the
private keys on the software.
Very often, as
we've seen earlier,
the attacks are really about
the weakness in the software
leaking out some of
the private keys.
So the third point is
you want to make sure
that those keys
are never exposed
during the manufacturing phase
of the connecting device.
So overall, the best
way of ensuring all that
is to make sure that
any of those keys
are never in the
microcontrollers that
are typically not designed for
hosting sensitive material.
ANTONY PASSEMARD:
The point number
three, Nicolas, is kind of
interesting, because people
don't realize that
there is actually
a risk of exposing keys during
the manufacturing process.
If you are leaving your
keys to your manufacturer,
oftentimes in countries
where IT levels may
be a little different,
there is definitely a risk
that those manufacturers
would copy those keys
and create fake devices
or copies of your devices
that are not legitimate,
and can be used to connect
to your architecture.
That's something
people don't realize.
NICOLAS SHIELI: Absolutely,
especially if you end up
generating keys or generating
the identity of those devices
on the manufacturing line.
So that may become a
very complex problem,
and you may need to invest
into securing the manufacturing
line in an environment where
secure manufacturing may not
be that obvious or
easy to implement.
ANTONY PASSEMARD: Right.
NICOLAS SHIELI:
So looking at how
we can implement a true,
trustable, identity
in your devices, so we basically
have come up with a product
line of devices that
basically are implementing
a few basic features.
One is to make
sure that whatever
you store in the device, whether
these are the private keys,
they are securely stored
in a non-volatile memory.
So that memory's
typically encrypted.
And you will have, also,
within a cryptographic hardware
boundary, so basically a
boundary that prevents someone
from looking what
is inside the chip,
you have also the
cryptographic engines.
So what you want
to do is you want
to have all those features
inside the cryptographic
boundary.
If any of those
features is outside,
your security is
potentially compromised.
Because the cryptographic
engine needs
to be able to have access
to the private keys
to be able to perform
its computation,
so you don't want
to have to move
the private key outside of
the cryptographic boundary
of the device.
Similarly, you want
to be able to have
a high-quality random
number generator.
Without any of this, you won't
have really true security.
So for instance, our devices
are capable of generating
their own keys, and they
are typically the output
of the random number generator.
So you need to have a very
high-quality random number
generator, or if
not, you would end up
being able to devise
keys quite easily.
ANTONY PASSEMARD: That's
an important point here.
You're saying that the random
key generator and the keys
and all of that is inside
the anti-tampering hardware.
That means-- that's the
hardware you can't open
with a screwdriver or anything.
You cannot access
what's inside of it.
But the private key is never
burned into that device.
It is generated by
the device itself.
It is never outside of it.
NICOLAS SHIELI: Absolutely.
So this is a very
important point.
So the private key
is something that
never exists outside of that
[INAUDIBLE] hardware boundary.
So basically, you don't want
to generate your key outside
and have to transfer
it inside the safe.
So the best way to
have a good protection
is to make sure that the secret
is generated within the safe.
So how is such device used?
So basically, overall, you have
essentially a microcontroller.
And on the side of
that microcontroller,
you would be adding
the crypto device
that contains the private key.
So the private key is
generated by the device.
And the microcontroller would
be generating a challenge that
is changing from time to time.
Every time you running
that challenge request,
it's going to be
a different one.
And that sends that
to the secure element.
And then the secure element
uses its private key
and the crypto engine to perform
the cryptographic function.
And the output is returned
to the microcontroller.
And the microcontroller then
has a response from the crypto
device that is verifiable.
So essentially,
the microcontroller
will be able to verify--
or the microcontroller
or the remote service
will be able to
verify-- that what
it's talking to has
knowledge of the private key.
And the device basically
is like a safe.
So the private key has been
generated inside the device.
The device is a secure element
with a cryptographic boundary
that is very protected with
many, many layers of security
that basically make the
retrieval of the private key
extremely challenging,
if not impossible.
ANTONY PASSEMARD:
And that device--
the ATECC608A here is a fairly
small device, if I recall.
NICOLAS SHIELI: Correct.
So the device is available in
a couple of package options.
So one is an 18 device, where
only a few pins are used.
But the smallest
one is basically
a two-by-two millimeter
[INAUDIBLE] that's [INAUDIBLE]..
So that's something that
is very difficult to spot
over any PCP [INAUDIBLE].
ANTONY PASSEMARD: Great.
NICOLAS SHIELI:
So the bottom line
is you want to be able to
have the safe really secure.
Right?
So the key is generated
in the device,
and you want to have
hardware protections that
prevent someone from being able
to get the key out of the box--
because again, if I know the
key, I have your identity.
Right?
So the whole identity
concept is based on the fact
that the private key
is private and secret.
ANTONY PASSEMARD: So you have--
NICOLAS SHIELI:
[INAUDIBLE] a number
of defenses that are
implementing in hardware.
So you can see on this
slide the obvious defenses
you have between the security
device and then, I would say,
a standard device that doesn't
have any hardware protection.
In a standard
device, you will be
able to see all the logic,
all the memory areas.
That means you would be
able to quite easily,
with quite standard
equipment, to be
able to get to the
memory locations
and read out the content.
So the security in the
ECC508 and 608 devices
have, as you can
see, an active shield
on top of the device
that basically
is a first layer of
protection, preventing people
from being able to easily
access the logic that
is in the device.
ANTONY PASSEMARD: Great.
So now we've seen-- we've talked
a little bit about the hardware
side of things, and a
very tiny crypto device
that can generate its own
keys and random key generator,
et cetera, and store
that very securely,
and serve the crypto engine.
Let's look at the cloud design
now, with Google Cloud IoT.
When we designed our IoT
platform at Google-- and we
have a lot of experience
building IoT devices.
All of you probably know the
Google Home and the Glass
and, you know, some of the Wi-Fi
hardware we have [INAUDIBLE],,
but there's been a challenge
across every type of IoT
devices, both in the
industrial and commercial world
and the consumer world.
It's always the same.
It's a security challenge.
That's what we're addressing
today, on securing the device,
securing the communication and
the identity of those devices.
The second problem is scale.
It's fairly easy to
connect a few dozen
to a few thousand devices,
a few 100,000 devices, even,
but when you start talking
about either millions of devices
or millions of messages per
second to a single endpoint,
this becomes really
difficult to do.
And this is what the
experience in scaling at Google
is very valuable in that area.
And finally, the
actionable insight
is very important,
because there's really
no point in connecting
devices if you're not
going to get insights
out of that connectivity
and out of the data.
And that's really a data
challenge, a big data
challenge, that Google
is very, very good at.
We have over seven
products that have
over a billion active users a
month, so we know our big data.
You're probably familiar with
Search, and Gmail, and YouTube,
and the way we serve ads.
Those kind of challenges
of managing and analyzing
very large amount of data
is one of the core strengths
of Google.
So we looked at that
with those core strengths
and those challenges, and
built our IoT Platform on that.
So if we look at the product
that we just announced,
it went off last May and
then launched in beta
a new service called
Google Cloud IoT Core.
Excuse me.
So Cloud IoT Core
is one new service
that's part of a suite that
creates our Google Cloud IoT
Platform.
It is the cornerstone of the
connectivity and the device
management.
So we'll communicate
bidirectionally with devices.
You'll be able to
define your devices,
manage them from IoT Core,
but then in terms of Dataflow,
the data will flow from
IoT Core to Pub/Sub,
which is a global messaging
service I'll talk about.
You can trigger Cloud
functions, which are serverless
processing units.
You can trigger
Dataflows, which are
the equivalent of Apache Beam.
It's the managed version
of the open source Apache
Beam, which allows you to
do processing over windows
of times, for example.
Over the last 20 minutes, look
at all the temperature coming
from those devices and tell
me what the average is,
and the bands, and am I out
of bands based on an average?
Things like that,
you do in Dataflows.
Very powerful tool,
all managed for you.
And then the data will
flow into a database server
like BigQuery, our data
warehousing tool, or BigTable,
for Node SQL.
Those data will be used
by our cloud machine
learning engine to create
models at very high speed, very
high accuracy, and
then those models
can be used in Dataflow or
even by your devices themself.
And we have some visualization
tool and Data Studio
and Datalab, [INAUDIBLE]
for your data
sent to manipulate the data and
create a better models overall.
So that entire suite is really
what is Cloud IoT for Google.
And all those tools are--
all of them are
managed services.
There's really no
operations to do with those.
So if we look a little bit
more into Cloud IoT Core,
there's two components to it.
One is the bridge,
the protocol bridge,
which support MQTT and
HTTP protocol endpoints.
We have a planet scale ingestion
and a planet scale consumption,
and I'll talk a little bit
about that in the next slide.
That's a very important
aspect of our platform.
We do automatic load
balancing, autoscaling
is a managed service for you.
There's no autoscaling
policy to create.
There's no cluster size.
There's no virtual machines, no
load balancers, none of that.
It's an endpoint that
you have in your project,
in your Google project,
and we scale it up and down
to your needs.
If during a month you send
no data or very few data,
you're going to
have a bill of zero.
There's really no upfront
cost to using IoT Core.
On the other hand is
our Device Manager.
That's where you
create your devices,
you create all the
attributes, you
can create hundreds of
attributes on devices.
This is where
you're going to have
your bidirectional
communication with the device,
with the notion
of a digital twin
being able to set states and
configuration for the device.
You'll be able to
have role-level access
control, which is an extension
of the security of the chip,
and also being able
to access all those
features through
APIs, command line,
and console [? scenery. ?]
So when I was talking
about global scale,
this is a very important
point for IoT Core.
This is actually a
very big differentiator
from other clouds.
Google is one of the
only cloud vendor
to own and operate its
own backend globally.
We own all the fibers.
We own the network globally.
That's how we serve ads
on YouTube that well,
because we have the network.
And when you create a
device and you connect it
to Cloud IoT Core, you
only need to know one URL.
It's called mqtt.googleapi.com.
That single URL is
used across the globe
to load balance traffic to
the closest access points
that Google has.
That means that if you have
your IoT core in the US, great.
But your device is in Australia?
You don't need to have
IoT Core in Australia.
The device will
automatically connect
to the closest pop in Australia
and use the fiber network
to get to the US to where
the data needs to live.
That gives us a scale that
nobody can provide you,
and that gives us the ability
to pre-configure devices
before you know where they ship.
You can just say,
mqtt.googleapi.com
on your device, and it
will connect everywhere.
We connect over port 443
natively, or 8883 also.
So we support-- we can go
through firewalls pretty easily
natively with IoT Core.
That's a very, very
big differentiator.
When the data lands in
IoT Core, I told earlier
that it goes to Pub/Sub.
Pub/Sub is also a
global product and means
that you don't have to think
about, oh, was that data posted
in Australia, or was
it posted in India,
was it posted in Europe?
You don't need to
think about that.
You'll just get the data out
of Pub/Sub to a single topic.
You get [INAUDIBLE]
several you configure,
and you'll get all that
data in your backhand
for your application
to be built on.
So that scale that
we have, [INAUDIBLE],,
very similar to this.
There's really
nothing to configure
for you, something that's
very differentiating
from other vendors.
In terms of authentication,
because we're
talking about security
and identity here,
this is an important area.
So here is how we do
the authentication
with Google Cloud IoT Core.
The device will establish a
TLS session with a Google Front
End, anywhere, one of
those hundred-plus pops.
And then we'll do
an MQTT connect.
In that MQTT connect, you have
a username that is ignored.
We don't use it.
And you have a password.
That password is a simple job
token, a very common concept
for web developers.
That job token is signed with
the private key of the device.
All right?
The private key of the device.
It is sent as the password.
There is no mutual auth
in the TLS stack, right?
It just sent as the password.
On the receiving
end of IoT Core,
we take that dot, we validate
with a public key corresponding
to that device that
we're sending the data,
we'll validate the signature,
and that mutual authentication
is established at that point.
So we don't depend
on the TLS stack
to do the mutual authentication.
That's a very important
point, because all
we need on the device
is the private key.
That's it.
No certificate,
no big TLS stack,
no dependency of the TLS
stack to the crypto hardware
like the microchip one.
You don't need to have a
special TLS stack for that.
If you do an update of your
TLS stack, it will still work.
You don't have dependency in
your code on that TLS stack.
That's a very important
differentiator as well.
It allows to have a much
smaller footprint on the devices
to establish quickly a secure
communication while keeping
the mutual authentication via
the signature of the job token.
So this is a very
important point
how we have worked on a few
different implementations
on our side, and we've been able
to have a Google Cloud IoT Core
authentication running on the
small [INAUDIBLE] product.
Yeah, that [INAUDIBLE]
thing was very impressive
because I had never
seen it before.
Because all the
stack is so small,
it can actually live
in the Wi-Fi module,
for example, entirely
in the Wi-Fi module
with very little memory.
NICOLAS SHIELI: [INAUDIBLE]
ANTONY PASSEMARD: So it's
very simple to implement.
NICOLAS SHIELI: Exactly.
ANTONY PASSEMARD: And
then next to that,
you can have an
eight-bit MCU that
is extremely cheap to read.
You know, read a temperature
or set a few settings
in the machine.
You don't need a
third two-bit MCU.
You can just do
the eight-bit MCU.
And that makes the whole
device much cheaper.
So this is more of a
visual representation
of that authentication.
In a typical flow, a provision
or person will create keys.
A public key goes to IoT
Core and the Device Manager.
A private key goes
on the device.
Then the device
generates the job,
finds it, sends it as part of
the connect as the password,
IoT Core looks at it,
validates the signature,
and opens the connection.
That's typical.
But you see the flow here.
The provisioner has
to create the keys,
and that private key lives
in the provisioner's hand
and has to be burned
on the device.
So that's where the partnership
with Microchip comes into play.
The partnership with
Microchip is much more secure
because if you buy that
cryptochip from Microchip,
because the cryptochip creates
its own private key inside
of it, it will generate
corresponding public key.
When you pass the secure
element to the device,
it's already programmed.
It's not in a file.
It's not anywhere in
the hands of anybody.
It is inside the chip.
That chip is put on the device.
The public key goes
to the provisioner
and is sent to the Device
Manager to be registered.
Then the rest of the
process is very similar.
The device creates a
job token, the job token
is signed by the crypto
device, the [INAUDIBLE]..
Natively, there's no
private key floating around.
It's done inside the SSc-608.
And that [INAUDIBLE] is
passed as the password
for establishing
the communication.
So using that model,
the key is never,
ever exposed, neither
to the provisioner,
neither to the device.
It's all inside that
very secure element.
And it makes it very
easy to connect.
NICOLAS SHIELI: So
in that context,
many developers of
connecting devices
may want to have their devices
as part of an ecosystem that
is managed.
So the way to do this is to
have a public infrastructure.
So luckily, Google Cloud IoT
Core has the ability to--
well, you have the ability
to load your own certificate
authority into the cloud.
So we can ensure that the
specific authority that
is managing, essentially, the
whole ecosystem of devices,
has done a good job of
protecting the private key that
comes with the
certificate authority.
So they are
responsible for having
that private key private.
ANTONY PASSEMARD: Yeah.
And that that
certificate authority key
is on a per-registry setting.
So we have-- per project, you
can create several registries.
So each registry can
have a CA authority
that's different or similar.
So you can use the same CA in
different registry if you want.
That's totally feasible as well.
NICOLAS SHIELI: So the private
of the CA is at the CA,
and that's why
you're using a CA is
because they defending
the service of protecting
that private key.
And then you typically
have a [INAUDIBLE] of CA.
So you have, typically, a
intermediate certificate
authority that is
below that root CIA.
So there's a signature
in between the two.
Thing is, very often what we
see in actual deployments,
people tend to do this on
the manufacturing line.
And that's a big problem because
the whole trust in the chain
depends on this second private
key being private all the time.
Because if someone has
access to that private key,
it would be able to sign
certificates of the devices.
Right?
And then basically,
the last level
is that you have the
device certificate,
and the private key
of the device that
is in a device in
the secure element.
And the secure
element, basically,
is the one that has generated
that last private key.
So that last private
key is essentially
secure for the whole duration
of their-- the whole lifetime
of the product.
So overall, you see
this chain of trust
may have a weakness
if the second key,
the intermediate
certificate authority,
is not correctly stored
in a secure supply chain.
ANTONY PASSEMARD:
And that's typically
in the manufacturing--
NICOLAS SHIELI: That's typically
what we see very often done.
ANTONY PASSEMARD: Right.
NICOLAS SHIELI: Because
that's a shortcut
that you may do when you're
implementing your manufacturing
line.
So at Microchip,
we basically worked
on trying to offer
a solution that
is very secure for the
customers without having
to even think about how to set
up their manufacturing line.
So that second key, which is
the intermediate certificate
authority, is
something that we offer
the service of
hosting the plan's
intermediate CA private
key and essentially
signing the individual
devices as part
of our standard
manufacturing flow.
So you don't have to invest
into a secure manufacturing
flow on your site.
You can buy devices
directly from us
that are signed by a chain
that is completely trustable.
ANTONY PASSEMARD:
So the customer
does not need a PKI at all.
Microchip provides that
entire infrastructure
with a secure manufacturing
line that's audited,
that has all the certifications,
can be audited by customers,
potentially.
And that means that when
the customer basically
just buys that cryptochip,
it's all done for them.
There's nothing
to manage at all.
They buy a crypto that
is already programmed,
already compatible
with IoT Core.
There is nothing to do for them.
NICOLAS SHIELI: Correct.
So a second intermediate
certificate authority
private key is stored
in our hardware security
modules that are on our
secure manufacturing line.
So this is something
that if you had
to deploy that yourself in
your manufacturing environment
is complex.
You need to have
the expertise, you
need to invest into the
hardware, which is obviously
not free, and
operate this, why we
have that whole
infrastructure ready to go
and we're doing this
in high volume today.
ANTONY PASSEMARD: It's not
about just the hardware here.
It's about access
from people who
operate in the manufacturing
line, the background
checks, the security audit.
NICOLAS SHIELI: It's
mostly about the expenses,
right, on how you
operate that, how
you design it to make it
secure during the lifetime
of the [INAUDIBLE].
Now thing is, if you invest
into that infrastructure
in your backhand,
you're basically
going to be doing
this investment once.
So now if you want
to change suppliers,
you're going to have to move
all of that or reinvest.
So it's quite expensive.
So initially, we
talked about the fact
that you have to
have two concepts.
So we spent quite some time
on the unique identity that
needs to be trustable
and verifiable,
but there's a second
concept that is
very important to IoT devices.
You need to have the
ability to verify
that the firmware that is
running on the microcontroller
is valid.
So you have basically
[INAUDIBLE] to have
a cryptographic key pair
for the firmware validation,
one which--
I mean, again, the
private key that
will be used to sign
the application image.
So the application
image that you
want to run on microcontroller
will first be hashed.
And that gives you
a firmware digest
and you will be signing that
digest with the private key
that is the device
manufacturer private key.
And the resulting
signature is something
that is appended to
the application image.
ANTONY PASSEMARD: So this is
another use of the SSc-608.
NICOLAS SHIELI: Correct.
ANTONY PASSEMARD:
The first one was
to store the keys to
authenticate to Google Cloud
IoT Core.
It's just with the same
chip, you can actually
do your firmware validation.
NICOLAS SHIELI: Correct.
So basically, you need to have
those two concepts implemented
in your IoT device if you want
to have a security device.
So this is the process
to sign your firmware.
But what is important
is that at one time,
you actually validate
the firmware.
So at one time, you had
your whole microcontroller
with the application image.
And you have the secure
element, the ATECC608A,
on the side that actually
contains the public key
of the signing private key.
And the host
microcontroller will
compute the digest of the
application image, will
send that digest
to the ATECC608A,
which will be able to verify
that digest corresponds
to the signature
with its public key.
And then we'll
authorize or reject
the application of
that application image.
So then the secure
bootloader, which
is a piece of code that runs on
a microcontroller that handles
the start of the overall
firmware of the product,
will, based on the
assistance of the 608A,
be able to decide whether the
firmware should be running
or not.
Now, the important point
is that if the 608A detects
that the firmware that has
been verified is not valid,
it will essentially lock down.
It will forbid the usage
of the private key that is
used to authenticate to Google.
So that means if the firmware
that is presented to the 608A
is not valid, the
device will refuse
to generate the valid job token.
ANTONY PASSEMARD: OK.
NICOLAS SHIELI: So you will
essentially be offline.
ANTONY PASSEMARD:
So you're not only
preventing the
image from loading,
but you're also preventing
the use of that key
to even connect to
your IoT core, which
is a second layer of security.
NICOLAS SHIELI: Yes.
So the summary.
Maybe, Antony, you
can talk a little bit
from your side what we've
been able to provide together.
ANTONY PASSEMARD: Yeah,
this was several months
of work with Microchip,
and we're really, really
happy about the results
because it's very much solving
a big problem.
If today, having a
PKI for your device
does not really
make sense, having
to generate certificates-- a
lot of customers talk to us
and they say, how
do I generate that?
Where do I store them?
How-- I mean, it's a pain.
It's a pain.
And I think that partnership
with Google and Microchip
really solves all that pain,
because all you have to do
is literally buy a
crypto from Microchip
and it's all configured,
all able to find a job,
able to secure the job,
validate your firmware.
To allow the security
things that you literally
have to do on devices,
but also on a very, very
tiny, tiny device.
And I want to emphasize that
this is not, in terms of cost,
this is not something that
is going to add dollars
to your implementation.
I mean, you want to
comment a little bit on--
NICOLAS SHIELI: Yes.
So basically, if you're
buying just one device,
it's basically less than $0.80.
ANTONY PASSEMARD: Oh, OK.
NICOLAS SHIELI: If you're
going to, like, 5,000 devices,
you're below $0.60.
So it's very affordable.
ANTONY PASSEMARD: So if you
think about $0.60 low volume,
$0.60 per device, to avoid
having a PKI, a complete PKI,
avoid having to open--
to be in the news as
one of the device that's
hacking or doing DDOS
attack on the DNS
servers and the internet, that's
actually a fairly low price.
And it's such a small
footprint that you can clearly
add it to almost any design.
NICOLAS SHIELI:
Yeah, you can always
find space on your
PCB to add this
on the side of microcontroller.
So the level of security
provided by their partnership
is very exciting.
The simplicity is
amazing, really.
And it can really work with
any microcontroller processor,
especially because the IoT
Core authentication is not
dependent on the TLS stack that
runs on those microcontrollers.
So that makes it very easy to
be compatible with any device,
as long as you can have an
MQTT stack or an HTTP stack,
you can have a simple TLS stack
just to connect to Google,
and the ability to create a job.
That's about what you need on
the device, so very, very tiny.
We're really excited
about this solution today.
It is available today.
NICOLAS SHIELI: It is.
ANTONY PASSEMARD: It
is available today.
NICOLAS SHIELI: And
we do have tools
to get started very easily.
So we have a number
of hardware boards
that you can purchase today
from the Microchip website,
and we have, here,
a link that will
be available in the presentation
at the end of this webinar.
You can go to this
page and you will
be able to buy the hardware.
And it's basically a
basic microcontroller
along with a Wi-Fi device, and
the secret element, ECC608A,
that you can plug together
in a very simple way.
And we have all the source
code that we talked about
on this hub, so everything is
referenced on that web page.
So you can go load the firmware.
You can modify it to your needs.
And we have even some examples
on how to control a fan
or temperature sensor.
So you have more than
examples, rather than
just the connectivity.
ANTONY PASSEMARD: Excellent.
So those are very
readily available to buy.
In IoT Core, if you sign up
for a Google Cloud Platform
account, IoT Core
has a free tier.
So you can--
IoT Core is charge on
the bandwidth usage,
only there's no notion of
number of devices or number
of messages.
Doesn't really matter.
It's a matter of bandwidth.
How much data are you
sending or receiving
from that MQTT bridge.
And there is a free [? tier ?]
250 megabyte per month
that you can just use for
free to get your first devices
connected and tested.
And after that, it's a
fairly downward slope
in terms of price as you
go up in volume of data.
So a very competitive
pricing overall,
only based on volume of data,
not on number of devices,
not on number of
messages generated.
So you can get started.
There's two links here.
cloud.google.com/iot, you'll
land on the Cloud IoT page.
You'll be able to have access to
the documentation, some sample
codes in many of the
common languages.
On the Microchip
side, microchip.com/AT
ECC608aGCPiotCore.
Here, you'll find the devices
that Nicolas was talking about.
You'll find sample code as well.
It's very easy to get started.
And we thank you very
much for your attention
and participating
in that webinar.
We have a few questions
now, so we'll go to that.
One of the first question
is, what is the level of FIPS
offered?
That's for you, I think.
NICOLAS SHIELI: Yes.
So basically, FIPS-- it's not
that FIPS [INAUDIBLE] device,
but you have a number of
things they can do around FIPS.
You can have a
CAVP certification
for your algorithms,
which is something
that we do for the 608A.
That's one thing.
And the second thing is you
want to have a FIPS capable
of random number generator,
which is also something
that we have in that device.
So we have the FIPS-based
random number generator
that is implemented.
And we have also the
newer specification
for the help desk.
So that means the
device will be verifying
that the randomness of the
number that is being generated
is at the right level at
the time of generation.
Because you could have
a very good entropy
for your random number
generator in your lab,
but that doesn't say
anything about what's
going to happen in
the device once you
are in the field, different
temperature, different voltage.
So these are things that are
addressed by the help desk that
is implemented in the device.
So this is a new stand from
FIPS that essentially tells you
how to do the random
number generator,
and we have it coming
back in the 608A.
ANTONY PASSEMARD: Great, great.
NICOLAS SHIELI: Also,
in addition to this,
we have been working
on the penetration
testing with third-party labs.
That gives you, essentially,
a [INAUDIBLE] level
so that you can get an
evaluation on how robust you
are against known attacks.
And we've been working
with a lab in Europe
that is really typically works
on computer certification.
And the [INAUDIBLE]
level evaluation
is something that is typically
one of the first steps
of the computer certification.
So the combination of the FIPS
compliancy for the algorithm,
the random number
generator, and the proof
that the penetration
resistance is very high,
is something that we can provide
to the interested customers
if they really want
to look into this.
ANTONY PASSEMARD: Great.
So the second
question is around are
we going to be able to
provide the presentation
or provide the recorded
version of the webinar?
I believe this is recorded
and then will be available,
if I am not mistaken.
So I think the answer
is yes to that question.
Can the [INAUDIBLE]
token be copied and used
in replay attacks?
Does the IoT mode require RTC
to provide a timestamp element?
NICOLAS SHIELI: So you don't
need an RTC, but you need time.
Yes.
So the job token is valued
for some amount of time,
and you need to have
time at this point.
So you're going to get time
from [INAUDIBLE],, for instance.
So the job token,
when it's signed,
has a creation date
and an expiration date.
And on the Google
Cloud Platform site,
it will be accepting tokens
that are within that time frame.
It is a policy based thing.
ANTONY PASSEMARD: Yeah.
So to clarify-- so when
you create your job,
you can specify an expiration.
NICOLAS SHIELI: Correct.
ANTONY PASSEMARD:
So first, you can
say my job will be only valued
for 20 minutes, or 10 minutes,
or whatever.
The upper bound of
that is 24 hours,
and there's a little bit of--
I think there's a few-minute
lag window around that.
So no more than 24 hours, but
if you specify in your job
that it's a 20-minute,
30-minute, two-hour validity,
then this is what the job
can be used for in terms
of [INAUDIBLE].
But remember, you need
to sign that [INAUDIBLE]
with a private [INAUDIBLE].
It's not only copying
the [INAUDIBLE],,
you need to have access to
the private key to sign it,
otherwise you won't be able
to use that [INAUDIBLE]..
NICOLAS SHIELI: Right.
So you don't need
[INAUDIBLE] hardware,
because you're
typically connected,
so you are able to get time.
ANTONY PASSEMARD: So let me
see other questions here.
Is it possible to do
firmware device update
and then update the ATECC608A
with a new hash secure boot?
Yeah.
NICOLAS SHIELI: Yes, so
that's an important point.
So indeed, the 608A
has a few features
that allow you to handle
this use case of [INAUDIBLE]..
So basically, the 608A
will, the first time
you're going to be using
it, will receive the hash
from the microcontroller
and then will
receive the signature that was
generated by the private key
at the time of
signing the firmware.
It will receive those two.
It will validate
that they are valid.
If they are valid, it
will store them both.
Right?
Now, if you're coming
up with a new firmware,
it will be a new signature.
So you're going to be
passing the new digest
with a new signature.
And then the device is able
to, again, be matched, verified
correctly with the public key.
We'll update its content
with the new signature
and a new digest.
ANTONY PASSEMARD:
There's quite a lot
of questions around the OTA.
I know somebody says here,
will TR generally [INAUDIBLE]
verify today?
Can a [INAUDIBLE]
608 to verify the OTA
for an IoT device that's
connected to [INAUDIBLE]??
NICOLAS SHIELI: Yeah,
that's actually--
so the 608A is an
upgrade from a product
that we've been shipping
in very large volume
up to quite recently.
So we launched a 608A
in November last year.
Before that, we've been sending
the 508A in quite large volume,
but the 608A is
really an improvement
on a number of
things, especially
the firmware
validation to make it
simpler to be able to correctly
support those OTA use cases.
Also, the improvement on
the random number generator,
because again, now
FIPS has a way--
they have finalized the way of
verifying the random number is
good enough at runtime.
So we have implement this.
ANTONY PASSEMARD: Yeah.
One other question is,
is the integration effort
of the root of trust with
a secure bootloader high?
NICOLAS SHIELI:
No, overall-- so we
have a few examples
on our website
on how to implement
secure boot for what
the scheme address presented.
We have a few examples
on our website
that give you example
codes on how to do this.
So the implementation
is quite simple.
So the bootloader portion of
the code needs to exist, rigth?
Obviously, the bootloader
is communication-dependent,
so it's something that
could be, depending on how
you're receiving the new image,
so that's something that we
cannot really provide examples
for all the use cases,
because they are all dependent.
Assuming that you have a way
of getting your new firmware
into the device,
then the 608A can be
used to validate the firmware.
ANTONY PASSEMARD: Cool.
The questions are flowing.
I can't answer all of them.
Does Microchip also have
application examples
using pick NCUs?
NICOLAS SHIELI: So all of the
examples we have on the website
right now are
using on-base NCUs,
but we do have customers
using pick devices.
So we have all our libraries
that can work on pick devices
as well.
ANTONY PASSEMARD: Great.
That's awesome.
We're being thanked
for the webinar.
So thank you for the
person who posted that.
He's asking about a
real estate use agent.
Would you have a
chip in the building,
or in the wall and other
collection of information
on the state of that building?
I mean, a building use case is--
just so you know, we have
hundreds of buildings at Google
that are very, very connected.
And we're actually implementing
IoT Core to connect
all of those right
now, and we're
looking at usage of that
crypto wherever possible.
The goal of the
crypto is really to be
used on each device if possible,
if those devices are IP
enabled.
If they're not IP enabled,
you could have those crypto
at the gateway level as well for
the building, if you have that.
If you have a back
net in your building,
you may have some
devices that won't really
be able to use the crypto.
That authentication can be
done to a gateway that uses
the crypto device [INAUDIBLE].
So yeah, a lot of example.
We have a great, by the
way, a partner for building.
It's called Candi Control.
They're connected to IoT Core.
They have a great
partnership with Google.
So if you have implementations
for smart building,
look at those guys.
Candi Control.
C-A-N-D-I. They have great
solution for smart buildings.
Can the ECC 508 also be used
for Google Cloud Services?
NICOLAS SHIELI: Absolutely.
So the 508A, as I mentioned,
has been in production
for many years.
The 608A is an
improvement over that
in terms of making the
secure boot validation,
I mean, the firmware
validation simpler
and be able to handle
easily the OTA use case.
So the 508A can do very
much the same thing.
So we can hold the
private key that
is used for signing in
job token in the 508A
very similar to the 608A.
ANTONY PASSEMARD: Great.
And does Google Cloud
IoT support IPv6?
That's a very good
question, because not
every Cloud provider
support that.
So remember when I told you
about the Google network
that we're using?
This is one of the cool
stuff about building products
at Google.
We built it on an
infrastructure that's so, so big
and battle-tested and has so
many features that we just
get those for free.
The Google Front
End supports IPv6,
so IoT Core supports IPv6.
That's one of the
beauties, that you
can connect with
an IPv6 protocol
to the Google Front End,
and then from there,
you're on our network.
You're in IoT Core,
no problem there.
So IPv6 is supported
by IoT Core.
Is IoT Core IaaS or PaaS, and
how would you describe it?
So IoT Core is a
fully managed service.
It's not an
infrastructured service.
It's almost [INAUDIBLE]
if you think about it.
It's an endpoint.
So when you log into
your cd console,
you'll see at the
bottom left, there's
going to be a link
called IoT Core.
You'll go in there.
The first thing you do
is you create a registry
and you give it a name.
And inside that
registry, create a device
and upload your public key.
That's all you have to do.
And that's it.
There's no
configuration, nothing.
Then you have
mqtt.googleapi.com,
that's your end point.
As I said, it's a
global endpoint.
You don't have to
think about where you.
think about the fact
that you're in Australia, in
the US, in Europe, in Japan.
Doesn't matter.
We'll [INAUDIBLE] to the
closest Google Front End
and get that traffic to the
region where you want it to be.
So there's one region
globally that you
use to have your Device Manager,
but the connectivity is global.
The data lands into
the region you choose.
So a fully, fully
managed service.
No load balancing
policy, nothing.
No scaling policy, no cluster,
no shards, none of that.
No VM, nothing.
No updates.
Everything is done for you.
It's a fully managed service.
How Cloud IoT Core help the
global corporation to scale,
as the number of
IoT-connected devices
can vary tremendously
across the globe?
I believe that's one
of our core strengths.
There's two things.
First, it's a managed
service by Google.
So we will manage the
scaling up and down for you.
You don't have to
think about it.
You can send us 10 million
devices, 20 million devices.
It doesn't really matter to us.
You don't have to
think about it.
That's our job to do.
And Google does that
really well, as you know.
Just look at YouTube and Gmail
and all those other services,
and search, and ad distribution,
all of that are superscaled,
and that's what we
use to power IoT Core.
The other thing is you're
talking about global scale.
The cool thing about the
global network we have
is because when you
use mqtt.googleapi.com,
it is globally distributed.
If you have a network of devices
that is globally distributed,
you will actually
automatically load balance
across the
hundred-plus Front End
that we have across the globe.
So you're not hitting the same
Front End by all your millions
of devices across the globe.
They will be
automatically distributed,
which helps a lot with
the distribution of upload
across the globe.
So we're really well
architected to do exactly
that, the big global
corporation ad scale.
And I think that's all
we have as questions.
That was quite a
good number here.
Please provide feedback
on the webinar.
There's a way to do
that through the tool.
We'd love to hear what you
liked, what was missing,
what you didn't like.
We'd be happy to do another
one later on as we have updates
on IoT Core, we have
updates on the ATECC608
and different implementations.
So happy to talk
more about this.
I think this is really
changing the game in terms
of security and IoT.
It brings simplicity
to our customers
while keeping the level
security at the highest possible
but removes all the hurdles and
works perfectly with IoT Core.
So we're really
excited about this.
And if we don't
have more questions,
I think we'll end
a tiny bit early.
Thank you, Nicolas
for being [INAUDIBLE]..
NICOLAS SHIELI: Well,
thank you for giving us
the opportunity of talking
about that great solution.
ANTONY PASSEMARD:
It's a pleasure.
Thank you very much.
And thanks everybody.
Oh, one more question.
Is there any common
criteria like evaluation
certification
planned for ATECC608?
NICOLAS SHIELI:
So as I mentioned,
we are doing-- so we were
not planning on certifying
the device for common criteria.
However, we are doing
penetration testing
for the 608A, which is
one step that is typically
early in the process of doing
common criteria certification.
So we can share the results
of that penetration testing
with our customers in a
NDA whenever they actually
have interest in that question.
And that will prove to you
that basically the key that
is inside the
device is correctly
protected for the
lifetime of the product.
ANTONY PASSEMARD: Great.
And somebody is asking
for a clickable link.
So I'm going to try to see if
I can post that in the chat.
Let me do that.
ATECC608A.
NICOLAS SHIELI:
[INAUDIBLE] IoT Core.
ANTONY PASSEMARD: Microchip
ATECC608A [INAUDIBLE]..
Damn.
Fat fingers here.
Sorry about that.
GCP IoT Core.
OK.
Loading.
[INAUDIBLE] Core.
You verify [INAUDIBLE] here.
And I'll post it in the chat.
ATECC608A GCP IoT Core.
OK, we're here.
So let me-- so how
do I share this here?
Is there a chat?
Chat, chat, chat, chat.
Presentation.
That working for everybody?
Let me know if you have
a problem with the chat.
So that's entered.
Up, here we go.
OK.
Cool.
We're at the end of it.
Thank you very much.
Great audience, actually.
There was quite a lot
of people watching.
That's cool.
And we hope this
will give you ideas
and more importantly,
we hope you'll
secure your next devices with--
NICOLAS SHIELI: Looking forward
to talking to some of you soon.
ANTONY PASSEMARD:
Thank you very much.
NICOLAS SHIELI: Thank you.
ANTONY PASSEMARD:
Have a great day.
Bye.